Stephen asks as a man I find it  extremely difficult to accept that other  men use Pinterest anyway I can overcome  this bias Stephen there's a way you can  overcome this bias it's called stop  being a dick that's all I've got for you  man you know I'm not trying to razz  probably trying to get a little time to  talk about the truce pecos 2012 Grenache  abut there's not much to go into it I  mean I you know I get it but if you're a  man that is trying to market or sell or  story-tell or create awareness to women  women are spending obnoxious amounts of  time on this platform at scale a major  leader and so if you're targeting  fifteen-year-old guys to 19 year old  guys to sell them sports equipment you  don't need Pinterest but if you want the  audience that lives there well then you  need to play there and your [ __ ]  bias is surely not helping you